The Joe Rogan Experience do you have a
favorite at all the movies you've done
well I like Batman because it was one
that was it broke nobody had any done
anything like that before right and I
had a big affair with conditioner over
there and we fell in love and I hired
all UFC fighters to fight my stuff
there's no such thing as UFC fighter but
no martial arts guys yeah so hit guys
from the tongue sword guys you guys went
to the hospital they got cut because I
pushed the limit on the damn thing and
we shot it on the table with the fight
sequences with the with the with the the
way we shot it everything that we did
it may not look like it today but in
those days
Tim Burton was going to use a six inch
knife I said no and we got the blade and
we got the guys and they did this thing
so Michael Keaton was a great [ __ ]
genius he was a great father the best
because he's the best actor in the world
he's one of the top five actress who's
ever lived he's looked at his career
look what he does look what he did on
stair on on quite loose or whatever it
is on Vicodin or whatever it is that
three hour piece is you know and I'm
sure he's in the program I would have
guessed a guest I know he did because I
hired him out of a movie called clean
and sober
and I saw in his eyes he could fight
because as a kid I got in so many fights
but I would read your eyes before I'd
even make a move if I saw something I
didn't like I'd probably figure a way to
get out of it
you know and that's how I went from
Hollywood
to the chairman of Sony
to biotech companies to this to that to
the UFC maybe it would have been great
um because I have good instincts and I
have I I kind of have like ordinary
taste let's say did people resist they
resisted Michael Keaton as Batman and
nobody wanted me yeah they didn't like
that idea because he was a stand-up
comic yeah they wanted a six foot three
guy to come in with the big muscles I
said no look in his eyes he's a killer
he'll stab you five times in the net
before you even know what happened
do your favorite Batman yeah Christian
Bale's a pretty [ __ ] good Batman too
bro he was really [ __ ] yeah those two
those two guys that that guy is willing
to do things that most people are not
willing to do like he's willing to get
fat he's willing to like almost die of
starvation that's how they have a career
yeah it's just like if you watch that
machinist which is not the best movie
but what's interesting about the movie
is just Christian Bale the fact that
he's basically a skeleton yeah he ate
like a can of tuna and an apple a day
crazy it's crazy and then like six
months later he was Batman yeah I know
jacked I know
you have to be crazy you have to be
crazy as my good friend and he's crazy
as a loon but it has to be it but and a
brilliant guy and thank God he kind of
retired like 10 years ago watch
Chinatown yeah I watch time I do I love
[ __ ] amazing I know like that guy of
course he's crazy how else could he be
that you can't
I'm standing on a corner La Cienega
Santa Monica
and with my wife at the time Leslie on
Warren she's pregnant with my son this
goes back 50 years ago maybe whatever it
was
Four Guys spoke by in the car and they
go Cinderella sucks and they flip it off
now I'm from the valley
so I said just wait she played
Cinderella on television that was her
thing so I said wait here I jumped in my
car and I chased these guys down the
street I caught him at a signal I came
up next I was about to hit him he said
no no I'm in her acting class man we're
all actors that was a joke whatever it
is
many years later I do
Witches of Eastwick
and we're going to meet Jack Nicholson
and as I walk in he looks at me says Hey
Cinderella sucks that was him
it was him that's hilarious yes
holy [ __ ] yes yes yes yes oh my God
that's hilarious yeah no I've got it you
almost beat up Jack Nicholson yeah no
but I mean that's hilarious that it's
him all those years later yeah I was
defending what I thought was my that's
my pregnant lady
how [ __ ] good is he in The Shining
yeah no he's not I watched that again
recently too
God he's a he's a he's a genius yeah
there's a few of those guys that like
they if you ever seen the video I'm sure
you have there's a video of him warming
up for his scene where he uh goes
through the bathroom door with the
hatchet yeah I saw it yeah and he's just
like jumping around the room and getting
himself fired up I'm like yeah he never
knew how to fight but he's a tough guy
yeah well he'll fight if he has to he
was an extraordinary big strong leg
Talent yeah there's there's people that
just like Captivate a story